82 j.j watt they did not retire 82 for
j.j watt at central michigan they did
retire number 99 for marshall goldberg
of the then chicago cardinals who played
for the team back in the 40s took a
break for three years to serve in the
navy in world war ii then came back and
finished his career
j.j watt
talking about
the number that was retired unless it
wasn't
99 back in circulation for the cardinals
here's jj what
finally made the decision on arizona i
looked at the roster and saw 99 was open
so i was excited about that
and then i later found out from a
different high school friend this is
evan so my my whole high school friends
and everybody's involved in this so
evan told me that 99 was actually
retired and that marshall goldberg
told me the whole story on that so i was
i said oh that's great because he had a
great story so i was already looking at
other numbers and options and then this
morning
when i saw the report
about ellen and her words that they
would like me to wear
i was touched i was literally it was i
felt
gratitude and thanks because i thought
that was a very special thing for them
to do and i'm extremely grateful for
first we appreciate that justin james
watt reads pft because that's where he i
would suspect saw the report about the
family member wanting jj watt to wear
the number but
look i want to be clear here i spoke
about this last night on pftpm very
candid with my beliefs i've written
about it tweeted about it
i have no less respect for j.j watt for
doing this yeah i would have
tremendously more respect for him if he
had passed
i have no issue with the family of
marshall goldberg
for saying go ahead and wear the jersey
because you could say hey a lot of
people know the story of marshall
goldberg now that didn't i
fine
the team is in charge of the number
and my point is this it's very simple
you know life is complicated life is
nuanced
there are very few things in life that
are simple
and when you set aside a number forever
you're setting it aside forever if
you're not ready to do that don't do it
just don't do it
be like the raiders who never do it be
like the cowboys who never officially do
it although unofficially nobody's ever
gonna wear number 12 again because of
roger staubach but if you if you're not
going to honor what it means to retire a
number
then just don't retire numbers it's not
like they they're the yankees and have
20 numbers retired it's larry wilson pat
tillman and a few other guys who have
never been in my kitchen whose names i
can't remember
but
but
and marshall goldberg at 99. and hey hey
i didn't know marshall goldberg was from
elkins west virginia i didn't know a lot
of things about marshall goldberg i
didn't know he wasn't in the pro
football hall of fame he's not they
tried to get him in two thousand
six seven ish didn't get in
so uh
great i know more about marshall
goldberg football historian like you
probably happy to know that too that
doesn't change the fact
that if you retire a number it should
stay retired i mean
this is a precedent that can apply to
any number that's been retired by anyone
because if there's a guy out there that
you want badly enough on your team chris
you can make the exception that you can
say well wow wow and the family says
it's okay what the hell else is the
family going to say that's they have a
story about steve largent he got
squeezed by the seahawks to give number
80 back to jerry rice he didn't want to
do it but he said it would have been
small of me
to say no you can't do it right no i
the the the player the ex-player the guy
that's had the jersey retired you know
the family you're right
that's the first thing i'll say they're
in a no-win situation when that gets
brought up and the organization just
doesn't squash it they really have no
other avenue unless they're just
comfortable
hearing the backlash and all that kind
of crap and doing that but i i will play
the other angle of kind of what you said
there you know the goldberg family
they might really be loving this right
now they might you know it's again it's
another way of hey look at grandpa and
great great grandfather and we're
talking about him he's in the news and
see see grandkids i you know or kids i
told you grandpa was you know an awesome
football player look at this and now
this guy's gonna do that so
you know there is something there to
that i understand your point but i do
think that family could obvi could could
be saying that same thing as well
now you know when it comes to the player
itself
it's tough you know first off players
are
creatures a habit
they are you know they're they're into
uh i'm blanking on the word i want to
use you know they but
superstitious thank you very much i
couldn't get that out of my head way to
go pete way to go uh
you almost were hemming and humming i i
was i couldn't figure out what the hell
that word was superstitious though
is is a real thing with a lot of
football players in the nfl and i'm sure
he feels like oh my gosh i i don't even
know what it's gonna feel like to play
another number i'm a hall of famer in 99
and there is that aspect as well so it's
a tough thing i hear your point i don't
think it's a make or break thing the
number's still going to be retired when
he gets done it's still going to be
there you know and he's going to have
that memory and i think there's there's
some value maybe in the goldberg family
really loving this and the attention
that you know the
grandfather great grandfather is getting
out of all this
so 100 years from now yeah if the
yankees acquire
some shortstop that wants to wear number
two
it's okay to say well you know what yeah
i know hey everybody's learning about
derek jeter all over again so we'll
and let's let's just hope that's every
day phil sims number 11 is retired right
you know i might be the first jerk that
goes
oh hey big time quarterback you want to
come to the giants where nope the sims
family has declined
i don't care about the social media hate
no
you might i might be the first if i get
to say in that and i don't want that day
to come of course because i love my
father very much but yeah i might be the
first one to go hey oh hey yeah
superstar quarterback nope find another
number there's lots of other ones
but my point here is it's the obligation
of the team to be the grown-up in the
room when something like this is going
on
and and and i i was a little irritated
about that yesterday and when i start
expressing my irritation and i hear
things from people connected to the team
like well you must really hate michael
jordan then because he unretired
multiple times like don't make that
don't make that that comparison
an individual deciding to unretire is
dramatically different from a team
saying this number is forever retired
yeah until it isn't and and that's the
point and you could make this argument
for any retired number for any retired
team
and and you know what you could also do
you could see a situation 150 200 years
from now whatever another reason not to
retire numbers but let's say there's
some rival baseball league that pops up
to to compete with mlb yeah some new
brand of baseball and they got some
phenom that mlb has a chance at getting
but he has one request he wants aware
number 42. right what do you think mlb
is going to do 150 years from now if
that comes along they're going to say
well you know everybody's learning about
jackie robinson again yeah we retired
the number for every team permanently
but you know
yeah the family said it was okay yeah i
know i hear you mike mike your point is
very real it is uh it certainly it's a
good discussion it's perfect for a show
like this and social media whatever else
but goal
hey if the goldberg family's cool with
it i'm cool that even though i know it's
a tough situation and you're right it
should be a little bit more on the team
to kind of draw that concrete line in
the sand and say nah we retired it let's
try to find a new number
i didn't like it when peyton manning put
the squeeze on frank for puka to wear
number 18 in denver i didn't like it
when jerry rice and or the seahawks put
the squeeze on steve largent i don't
like it i don't like it because if it's
retired it's retired and if you're not
willing to make that permanent
commitment
that that is the ultimate commitment
that is that is truly and literally
forever if you're doing it right if
you're not willing to do it then don't
do it just don't retire numbers don't
you can put the guy in the ring of honor
or whatever the equivalent name is you
can immortalize him in some other way
but when you're setting a number aside
that's a pretty damn big deal that's a
hell of a purchase that's a lot more
than a house or a car or a marriage
that is forever unless unless it isn't
that's the key yeah we're now at the
point in the evolution of the sports
industry that we realize it r when we
when we retire numbers
there's there's always that little
asterisk applied
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports